[Music]  Blake Lively has been a blonde bombshell  watching a racy redhead very brilliant  and now she's a brunette check out the  30 year old actresses new do here's  Blake practically unrecognizable with  that short shaggy cut on set in Dublin  Ireland filming her new thriller the  rhythm section it's definitely a look  we're not used to seeing on Blake but  there's no denying she's stunning no  matter her hair color the actress is one  of hollywood's most stylish stars always  taking risks and switching up her look  but still when it comes to glitz and  glam there's one opinion that matters  most her nearly three-year-old daughter  James what does James think of you when  you're all dressed up and looking so  incredible this she's very sweet she  says Wow very complimentary and that  means more to me than anything  [Music]